de ce dossier elle en passe au débat de
ce club vous le disiez c'est pas très
long en Françoise Gatel on va parler de
l'inflation des normes le Sénat chambre
des territoires s'est penché sur ces
normes qui étouffent parfois le
quotidien des élus on va longuement en
parler avec vous mais d'abord Audrey un
point sur ce qu'a fait le sel et bien ça
fait l'objet d'un rapport votre rapport
Françoise Gatel que vous cossignez avec
le LR Rémi quintro vous parlez de
harcèlement textuel les mots sont formés
il faut se rendre compte le code général
des collectivités territoriales à
tripler de volume en 20 ans il dépasse
le million de mots et le code de
l'urbanisme a gonflé de 44% en 10 ans le
comble et c'est ce que dénonce de
nombreux mères c'est qu'à chaque
tentative de simplification et bien en
fait on rajoute de la norme résultat les
élus se sentaient tout fait face à la
complexité certains n'osent même plus
entreprendre pour leur commune des
normes qui ont un coût Oriane 2
milliards d'euros de dépenses entre 2017
et 2021 d'après les services de la
première ministre car plus il y a de
normes plus les des projets sont
complexes prennent du temps voire du
retard il coûte plus cher aussi les
petites communes qui n'ont pas beaucoup
de ressources en interne doivent faire
appel à des experts et Audrey
glissénateurs proposent évidemment des
solutions et même une thérapie de choc
ce sont vos mots pour répondre à une
priorité exprimée par les élus encore
récemment dans les travées du Congrès
des mères vous proposez vous êtes la
chambre des territoires donc que le
Sénat soit informé par le gouvernement
en amont de tout projet de texte
normatif l'idée c'est d'anticiper et de
voir si le texte est nécessaire ou si
l'on peut faire autrement l'autre
proposition c'est une sorte de clause de
revoyure comme il existe déjà en
Grande-Bretagne en clair quelques années
après la mise en application d'une loi
on fait le bilan si les résultats ne
sont pas au rendez-vous ont la modifie
voire même on la supprime c'est ce que
vous expliquez il ne faut pas avoir peur
d'admettre qu'une loi n'est peut-être
pas forcément efficace pourquoi vous
avez choisi de vous intéresser à ce
sujet parce que quand on interroge les
mers sur leur préoccupations et des
choses qui les épuisent au sens où ça
les empêche d'agir c'est les normes on
n'arrête pas de le dire et je salue à la
lombaire qui a président mais vraiment
absolument fabuleux parce que c'est un
hussard de la norme un Lambert
on a un objectif c'est l'efficacité de
l'action publique donc l'idée c'est que
les élus puissent réaliser des choses
hors comme le dit aujourd'hui le
président de de la MF avant on cherchait
ce qui est interdit aujourd'hui c'est ce
qui est autorisé quand en plus il y
avait des normes contradictoires je peux
vous donner un exemple on va prendre le
zéro artificialisation vous allez voir
la mère de Croisic elle va vous dire
voilà moi j'ai une obligation de
construire des logements sociaux si je
le fais pas j'ai une amende et en même
temps avec la nouvelle loi je peux plus
construire donc vous voyez ce monde de
fournais et que nous on pense
qu'aujourd'hui avec la défiance de nos
concitoyens qui croient plus à l'action
puis ça ne marche plus il faut peut-être
qu'on pense un peu autrement et surtout
vous l'avez dit ça coûte énormément
d'argent
où on a des finances un peu délicates
peut-être peut-on optimiser la dépense
publique on va en parler on va poser la
question à l'envers le Hussard de la
norme c'est vous qui l'avez dit
Françoise Gatel absolument
comment vous expliquez à l'inverse à
cette inflation des normes aujourd'hui
c'est une longue histoire je pense que
nous sommes un pays centralisateur qui
finalement vit un centralisme
bureaucratique qui se perpétue de
génération génération et les lois de
décentralisation ont essayé de changer
ce paradigme mais on voit bien que en 40
ans puisqu'elles ont été prodigués il y
a 40 ans le pouvoir central ne cesse de
reprendre la main sur des pouvoirs qui
ont été conférés dans la réalité aux
collectivités territoriales si
l'explication
sociologique que nous pouvons je crois
faire tous dans la comme un accord
Jean-Baptiste on revient évidemment vers
vous à Lambert Françoise Gatel le disait
c'est un des sujets de préoccupation
majeure des élus oui c'est un sujet de
préoccupation des élus alors je lance le
débat avec vous Madame Gatel parce que
le le Parlement aussi ça part de
responsabilité moi j'ai regardé par
exemple la loi 3DS la dernière loi de
décentralisation
qui était censé être une simple loi
d'ajustement au départ on avait 83
articles on a fini à 271 articles après
l'examen par l'Assemblée et le et le
Sénat donc de ce point de vue là le
législateur a aussi une une
responsabilité l'exécutif aussi enfin
tout responsable tout ce coupable
l'exécutif on a aujourd'hui un
gouvernement pléthorique on a 42 membres
du au sein du gouvernement borne
évidemment chaque secrétaire d'État
chaque ministre veut imprimer sa marque
c'est bien c'est c'est bien naturel donc
on se retrouve effectivement avec une
inflation une explosion des normes qui
qui n'arrête pas moi je me souviens
d'avoir fait un article il y a plus de
15 ans mais il a pas pris une ride
responsabilité du Parlement dans cette
jeunesse exceptionnelle
et moi je ne dis pas c'est la faute de
je prends ma part et je veux dire c'est
vrai que parfois au Sénat les uns et les
autres pour démotivent qui sont valables
mais qui sont parfois locaux on vient
introduire dans la loi au niveau
national un amendement pour régler un
problème local mais qui va empoisonner
le reste de la France je dire moi je
partage et comme en même temps quand
vous prenez l'exemple de 3DS on est
passé de temps d'article à ton article
mais ici ils sont tous intelligents et
pertinents ça me gêne pas voilà c'est
c'est ça le sujet mais c'est un problème
aussi sociétal aujourd'hui je vais vous
donner un exemple qui est très fort moi
j'entends des maires dire voilà il va
falloir que la loi définisse des
horaires d'éclairage public parce que à
cause de de enfin du coup des normes
j'ai diminué mon éclairage public et
j'ai un concitoyen qui va faire un
recours contre moi pour défaut de
sécurité
et donc ça veut dire parce que la
société se comporte aussi comme ça parce
qu'on a un principe de précaution et de
juridiscalisation aussi
vous imaginez qu'un maire vienne à vous
demander ça donc moi je pense qu'on est
globalement
responsable et que parfois il peut y
avoir dans la loi une inflation de la
norme parce que on peut introduire une
adaptation de la norme je sais pas par
exemple pour la collectivité européenne
d'Alsace qu'on retrouve pas ailleurs
mais là où ça devient une folie c'est à
dire on a une machine à produire de la
norme est-ce qu'on pense que ça va nous
sécuriser alors qu'à un moment ça nous
met dans un corner et qu'on ne peut plus
on ne peut plus rien faire donc il faut
se détendre un peu il faut surtout
arrêter de produire de la norme et de la
loi il faut que l'administration a de
dans le législateur et viennent en
rajouter et que on essaie de se dire
qu'à chaque fois qu'on produit quelque
chose ça doit être utile Alain Lambert
vous avez été avant je le disais ancien
ministre ancien sénateur est-ce qu'il y
a aussi une responsabilité des exécutifs
des parlementaires dans cette inflation
des normes
non naturellement les responsabilités
sont partagées on ne peut pas le dire
cependant je voudrais faire marquer je
voudrais faire remarquer que nous sommes
dans un pays où le gouvernement ne
laisse pas aboutir un amendement qui ne
lui paraît pas justifié je veux bien
qu'on accuse le Parlement d'être à la à
la source de la complexité normative
mais je voudrais dire que tous les
amendements qui sont adoptés
généralement on fait l'objet d'un avis
favorable du Gouvernement donc si le
Gouvernement considère au contraire
qu'on doit aller vers la simplification
il pourrait essayer de d'empêcher le
Parlement de complexifier lui-même moi
je crois très franchement que nous
sommes dans une situation où il faut que
toutes les acteurs se mettent d'accord
pour
simplifier
rendre les textes qui sont aujourd'hui
trop compliqués beaucoup plus facile
beaucoup plus simple d'applications je
crois que c'est un un enjeu collectif
qui est possible de réussir dès lors que
toutes les parties considèrent que c'est
extrêmement
urgent et important et croyez moi c'est
urgent et c'est important parce que
Françoise Gatel l'a dit les élus locaux
n'en peuvent plus ils sont absolument
submergés par les règles qu'on leur
impose et ils ne peuvent plus être à la
disposition de leurs concitoyens est-ce
que vous avez le sentiment que ceux qui
font la loi ont conscience de cette
urgence et de cette importance dont vous
parlez
conscience mais ils font l'objet ils
sont l'objet aussi de demande
permanentes des populations il faut bien
le dire donc nous sommes dans une dans
une sorte de de
cercles vicieux si vous voulez et je
crois qu'il faut en sortir et je crois
que c'est possible d'en sortir vous
prenez l'exemple des coups nous avons
nous noter que entre 2017 et 2020 2021
les coûts ont été de 2 milliards d'euros
pendant le même temps les gouvernements
ont demandé aux collectivités
territoriales de baisser leurs dépenses
comment concilier ces deux
contradictions s'agissant des textes
même nous avons dû sur la même période
en subir 1500 plus d'un par jour et sur
ces 1500 il y en avait 30% qui ont été
présentés en extrême urgence
s'ils étaient en extram urgence avant de
dire qu'ils ont été improvisés or l'OCDE
en 2010 et en 2004 et en 2010 avait
proposé que la France est une stratégie
normative et nous notre proposition que
nous et que le Sénat est et François
Gatel et Rémi pintro
effectué un magnifique travail propose
justement que nous ayons chaque année
une sorte de
proposition des textes qui pourraient au
cours de l'année être adopté je crois
franchement qu'il faut remettre de
l'ordre dans la production normative
oui Alain Lambert le dit vous savez moi
je compare la fabrique de la loi ou de
la norme un procès industriel
c'est-à-dire avant de mettre sur le
marché
massivement un produit vous avez assuré
votre production du ciel que vous avez
fait un prototype non non c'est comme si
on se levait le matin les gens qu'est-ce
qu'on pourrait faire aujourd'hui voilà
on a un problème alors on va faire ça
donc on y va mais vraiment plein de
bonnes intentions et sans doute qu'on
peut y être et alors on lance la ferme
voilà ce formidable et prenez l'exemple
encore du Zéro artificialisation mais
toute la loi notre et on se marche pas
ce cette affaire là donc vous voyez ce
qu'elle a Lambert dit c'est exactement
ça c'est-à-dire je pense qu'il faut que
culturellement on partage cela tous et
moi je trouve qu'il y a une progression
des esprits à Lambert fait allusion
travail remarquable qui fait au cnen on
a participé tous les deux ainsi que
David Lisnard le président de la mettre
un colloque du Conseil d'État le Conseil
d'État lui-même dit ça suffit si nous
travaillons mieux en ayant réfléchi à ce
qu'on faisait aux conséquences et aux
impacts ça marcherait mieux ce serait
plus paisible Jean-Baptiste oui c'est
une question éminemment politique portée
par par David Lisnard qui se bat contre
ce qu'il appelle le Léviathan le
Léviathan estatique et effectivement
c'est une question quand même
démocratique c'est d'ailleurs qu'on a
des administrés qui qui qui en perdent
leur latin enfin en principe on dit nul
n'est censé ignorer là la loi et
aujourd'hui plus personne ne connaît la
loi y compris les maires enfin certains
maires disent il faut il faut avoir il
faut avoir fait l'ENA pour être pour
diriger une petite commune justement on
va voir l'un des mers puisqu'on le
disait cette addiction aux normes elle
est dénoncée par de nombreux élus locaux
on va avoir un exemple concret concret
avec l'un d'entre eux le maire dit le
crise graphen Staden c'est dans le
Bas-Rhin il y a un effet les étalez le
rencontrer
ici toute cette parcelle là et vraiment
dévoluer à accueillir le maraîchage et
on souhaite construire un bâtiment type
ferme et on fait un projet qui permet
d'alimenter à la fois les cantines de la
ville mais aussi peut-être de faire de
la vente en direct aux habitants mais
pour garder ses champs à l'état
agricoles le maire fait face à un
casse-tête administratif le sort de
cette terre est scellé dans un PLU un
Plan Local d'Urbanisme la précédente
équipe municipale voulait transformer
ses espaces en logement mais le nouveau
maire décide de les maintenir à l'état
agricole il doit donc transformer une
ZAC une zone d'aménagement concerté en
Zap zone d'agriculture de proximité
et donc on est parti pour deux ans de
procédure d'enquête publique enfin voilà
c'est pas aujourd'hui un problème de
financement ou de candidats c'est un
problème aujourd'hui de normes des
règles qui se sont multipliées ces
dernières années de nombreux maires
dénoncent des procédures à rallonge pour
eux des freins à l'action elles sont
aussi un motifs d'incompréhension
souvent évoquées par les administrés on
passe aussi même vis-à-vis du citoyen
pour pour des gens pas toujours sérieux
qui suivent pas les dossiers et l'usager
se dit mais enfin pour c'est très
compliqué pour pour pas grand chose
parce que le résultat à la fin quand
vous le voyez vous vous dites pas qu'on
a réalisé à un viaduc ou qu'on a créé
une nouvelle ligne de chemin de fer
enfin voilà il y a rien d'exceptionnel
ça ça rend les choses plus complexes et
j'ai le sentiment quand même qu'il y a
une perte financière parce que la durée
vous la payez de toute façon et plus ça
dure longtemps plus vous payez il
demande donc une simplification des
procédures pour cet élu une nécessité
d'intérêt général c'est ça on fait pas
forcément confiance au bon sens et on a
l'impression qu'en fait à chaque fois on
nous rajoute on en rajoute des règles
qui se sur la joute déjà
à la rivière des règles face à laquelle
à chaque fois on se heurte l'abondance
c'est la complexité des normes montant
un coup pour la commune Illkirch doit
employer des juristes pour guider
l'action de l'administration
et on fait pas forcément confiance à la
notion du bon sens c'est ça aussi mais
il a tout dit mais il est excellent
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui le bon sens
et peut emprunter et qu'on a besoin de
normer et surtout de définir ce qui est
un peu interdit avec cette complexité
enfin quand on l'entend expliquer qu'il
doit transformer sa Zac en fin voilà à
un moment c'est des histoires tragiques
à la Devos quoi Devos nous faisait rien
avec ça mais vous voyez puis derrière et
au final c'est ce que l'on dit
c'est-à-dire comment allez-vous
expliquer un concitoyen que vous pouvez
pas lui permettre de faire juste un
petit cabanon dans son jardin parce que
vous comprenez il faut que vous
transformiez ça il y en a pour trois ans
et demi donc nous concitoyens pensent
que les les élus sont pas à la hauteur
quoi
et sincèrement on a aujourd'hui un vrai
problème démocratique et imaginez
pendant la crise sanitaire dans mon
département d'ille-et-vil comme partout
moi j'ai eu des maires de petites
communes ils ont une petite école ils
reçoivent le vendredi soir à l'époque un
protocole sanitaire de 95 pages pour eux
tout le monde a oublié que dans une
mairie une petite main de vendredi soir
il y a personne pour lire le protocole
sanitaire que l'école doit ouvrir le
lundi et le maire il est tous seul avec
cette chose et lui il gère avec du bon
sens si vous permettez je vais vous
donner un exemple protocole sanitaire
pour la réouverture des cantines et des
écoles 95 pages et on vous explique dans
votre école vous devez avoir un nombre
de lavabos qui dépend du nombre
d'enfants que vous avez doivent être
espacés pour voilà bon amer me dit moi
j'ai une école elle est comme elle est
un enfant né au mois de juin moi on est
quand la répond pas du tout aux normes
qu'est-ce que je fais je fais mon école
je l'ouvre pas non non ce maire qui est
dans une commune d'Ille-et-Vilaine il va
alors personne ici nous connaissait chez
Agrial agréable dans un magasin de
fournitures agricole et le maire il va
acheter des abreuvoirs que l'on met pour
les animaux dans les champs il les
installe ces abreuvoirs le long du mur
extérieur de l'école les enfants sont
archi à vivre c'est beau en plus voilà
et il me dit moi tu vois ça m'a rien
coûté en plus quand il y en a plus
besoin pour l'école je vais les mettre
au terrain de foot pour les gamins vous
voyez le maire il a inventé un
dispositif sanitaire génial tout bête
qui lui coûte 3 francs si et donc
quelquefois on laisserait le bon sens et
ce que le maire porte en lui c'est cette
obligation de trouver une solution il
s'est envie de faciliter la vie de nos
constructeurs franchement ce serait plus
simple ça nous coûterait moins cher et
ça nous prendrait beaucoup moins de
temps à l'envers pour rebondir là dessus
c'est sur ces exemples très parlants
est-ce que finalement il faut laisser
plus de place au bon sens
tout à fait si nous prenons l'exemple
concret que Françoise vient d'évoquer si
la règle de droit n'avait pas été faite
sous forme de décret ou d'arrêter mais
comme un sable guide de bonne pratique
le maire en question de ce serait pas
posé la question de savoir si violet le
droit ou pas donc on voit bien que ce
sont les instruments qu'il faut revoir
les instruments des guides de bonnes
pratiques devaient remplacer la moitié
des décrets et des arrêtés qui
aujourd'hui régissent l'action publique
locale
Jean-Baptiste est-ce que les mères ils
sont freinés ils sont paralysés dans
leurs actions du quotidien et est-ce que
du coup ça a des conséquences sur leurs
habitants oui c'est des conséquences sur
sur leurs habitants il y a eu un effet
quand même crise sanitaire enfin on a
basculé quand même dans l'absurdistant à
certains à certains moments d'ailleurs
les mers se sont portés vraiment en
première ligne on se souvient qu'il
fallait pas nous mettre de masque au
départ on se souvient du maire de sceaux
qui avait qui avait souhaité imposer le
masque et il a été retoqué à la partout
tous les pouvoirs
administratifs donc de ce point de vue
là les mères sont quand même largement
largement entravés dans leur dans leur
action quotidienne on a une
administration qui a tendance à sortir
le parapluie quand même très très très
très facilement et c'est un peu l'un des
paradoxes quand même de la macronie qui
devait être la start-up nation et qui
fait quand même pas preuve d'une très
très grande agilité en matière en
matière de normes Françoise réponds
se désintoxiquer de cette addiction non
alors nous on avec mon collèguemines
samedi bon alors les normes ça peut être
le marronnier des élus hamster comme
vous dites ça fait 15 ans qu'on en parle
donc à un moment
si vous pouvez arrêter d'en parler c'est
ça sert à rien voilà donc on s'est dit
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire et donc nous
on propose
une conversion si je puis dire
à une fabrique de la loi et de la norme
plus raisonnée et donc on a fait six
recommandations très simples en disant
il faut peut-être que le Gouvernement
n'abandise au Parlement ben voilà cette
année on va parler de ça qu'on en
discute qu'on travaille avec les
parlementaires avec les associations du
convoi si on a vraiment besoin d'une loi
on a peut-être pas besoin d'une loi et
on n'existe pas parce qu'on a une loi
qu'on expérimente et qu'on met ce qu'on
appelle une clause guillotine
c'est-à-dire ok on le fait mais cette
loi elle est en vigueur jusqu'à
merci d'ailleurs on fait une sorte de
CDD les législatives et si il y a pas eu
de révision et d'évaluation la loi elle
tombe et surtout nous nous allons
proposer concrètement au mois de mars
des états généraux de la simplification
alors ça peut paraître
voilà mais on va le faire et j'en suis
très heureuse naturellement avec le
Conseil national d'évaluation des normes
qu'il faut absolument muscler qui est
une instance indépendante musclée
concrètement ça veut dire quoi
sincèrement expliquer moi comment on
peut avoir une évaluation de la qualité
de la loi présentée au cnen en urgence
quand on plus l'étude d'impact elle est
faite par les services du ministre qui
défendent la loi le ministre il va pas
se contrarier donc voilà donc on a un
sujet et donc dans cette charte
d'engagement nous on invite le
gouvernement aux États généraux avec le
sénon des associations d'élus pour
est-ce qu'on se peut se mettre d'accord
sans changer la loi
pour une charte d'engagement c'est en
définit un process de fabrique de la loi
et de et de la norme donc le cneen voilà
je pense que
à Lambert est très stimulant sur ce
sujet les associations des lieux aussi
le Conseil d'État est très encourageant
et donc madame la Première ministre a
été invitée à venir à vous a répondu
on va
dans ma question non plus on va demander
à on va demander à Alain Lambert sur les
préconisations de Françoise attelle il y
a la clause guillotine il y a ses
process pour fabriquer la loi ça ça vous
paraît le bon chemin ça
nous avons beaucoup apprécié les travaux
qui ont été menés par Françoise Gatel et
rémytron je pense que si nous les
appliquons nous devrions trouver déjà
une très très grande part de solution je
voudrais dire que le paradoxe c'est que
nous avons des lois et notamment une loi
organique qui normalement devrait nous
permettre de ne pas nous retrouver dans
cette situation là la l'organique de
2009 prévoit que tout texte qu'il soit
législatif qu'il soit réglementaire doit
être précédé d'une étude d'impact alors
c'est une impact est aujourd'hui
négligée et comme le rapport de
Françoise Gatel le démontre très bien
c'est cette étude d'impact qui devrait
nous permettre de voir s'il y a utilité
à légiférer ou à réglementer si nous
ratons cette étape il va de soi que le
texte qui sera promulgué n'atteindra pas
ses objectifs voilà pourquoi je crois
que nous devons mettre en vigueur les
propositions qui sont faites en tout cas
le CNN les soutiens je voudrais prendre
exemple chaque année nous avons un débat
d'orientation budgétaire qui permet qui
oblige le gouvernement à indiquer
quelles sont les grandes orientations
qu'il va donner au finances en recette
et en dépense je vois qu'il pourrait y
avoir un débat d'orientation normatif
qui obligerait le gouvernement à
indiquer chaque année quels sont les
principales lois qui leur envisagent de
proposer quels sont les principaux
règlements qu'il propose de mettre en
oeuvre ça permettrait aux associations
nationales d'élus ça permettrait à tous
les acteurs de commencer à travailler
sur les sujets de pouvoir organiser des
concertations d'arriver à des textes qui
réuniraient un consensus beaucoup plus
large que celui au rythme du auquel nous
sommes aujourd'hui soumis c'est-à-dire à
30 40% de saisie dans l'urgence merci
Alain Lambert ce sera la conclusion de
ce débat on suivra le 16 mars vos
travaux Françoise Gatel on en reparlera
ben nous comptons sur vous mais on en
reparlera promis on vous invite à ce
moment-là
de nos jours nos originaux
[Musique]